This episode is brought to you by Ridge wallet.
Hey, wisecrack.
Michael here to remind you that.
There's no war in bosses. Of course there is.
It's very much a war going on, and that's what we're here to talk about.
Avatar might look like just another cheerful kids cartoon about folks throwing
magic at each other,
but it actually might be the best exploration of war we've ever seen in
children's television.
It may not be the only kid show to depict armies and chosen ones,
defeating evil Lords,
but avatar goes above and beyond to show an unexpected side of armed conflict.
So what exactly is it? Let's find out in this wisecrack edition on avatar,
the last Airbender, and of course, spoilers ahead.
But before we dive into the a hundred year war,
I want to give a shout out to this episode. Sponsor rich,
rich creates quality products that redefine the everyday essentials,
their wallets, backpacks phone cases,
and chargers are all crafted with a minimalist design that doesn't sacrifice
function. Their flagship product. The Ridge wallet is a prime example.
It is light, sleek and durable.
It doesn't fold awkwardly or bulge in your pocket,
but there is still enough room to fit all your cards and cash.
The Ridge wallet holds up to 12 cards and has a cash clip.
It comes in over 30 different styles and is made out of carbon fiber,
aluminum and burnt titanium.
The wallet is so durable that it even protects against digital pickpockets with
its RFID blocking technology. The Ridge is so confident that you'll like it,
that you can test drive it for 45 days. And if you don't love it,
you can send it back and get a full refund.
So get 10% off your Ridge wallet today, by going to
rich.com/wisecrack that's ridge.com/wisecrack and use the promo code wisecrack,
they offer free worldwide shipping and returns. So check it out.
Now back to the show. Avatar takes place in a world,
divided into four elemental nations.
The avatar is tasked with keeping them in harmony by learning to manipulate all
four elements and acting as a global peacekeeper things start to go wrong.
When the fire nation begins its campaign for world domination.
While the current avatar is still just a 12 year old kid named Ang terrified by
his responsibility,
Ang fleas in the middle of a storm and ends up plunging into the ocean where he
lies frozen in ice for the next hundred years,
when he wakes up the world around him has been ravaged by a century of war from
the beginning.
The show refuses to shy away from the effects of such a widespread drawn out
conflict. We meet siblings,
Katara and Saka who have lost their mother to the war and are tasked with
providing for their village while their father is away fighting.
We also quickly find out that an entire home in people have been destroyed,
rough stuff. And here from the very beginning,
we get a sense of what avatar is really about the human cost of war.
Once our trio embark on eggs quest to master the elements,
they feel the effects of the war everywhere they go.
Once peaceful villages have become police States.
Thanks to the occupying forces while the great city of Boston say has instituted
mind control methods to maintain a totalitarian order.
There's even an episode where villagers get poisoned by a nearby arms factor in
another featuring in imprisoned political dissidents, everywhere our crew goes.
They meet people who have lost partners, friends, and family.
We also get some realities of war dressed up as childish euphemism and the very
first episode Katara Warrens Ang not to go into an abandoned fire nation.
Just in case it's booby trapped, Ang stop. We're not allowed to go near it.
The ship could be booby trapped.
This is a kid-friendly way to present.
What is a reality for many children who grow up in current or former war zones,
watch out where you play.
There might be some unexploded bombs or hidden landmines turned around and as
they begin their travels,
they find that almost everyone else has had their sense of home effected by the
war in some way, for many people, this means the loss of that home altogether.
One episode CS Ang, and the gang guiding a group through a dangerous route,
inhabited by a deadly giant snake,
a fantastical take on the plate of real world refugees who traverse all kinds of
dangers in the hope of arriving somewhere safe. Likewise,
we also meet a group of exiled earth, kingdom civilians,
living in the remains of an abandoned air temple.
As the last living member of the air nation Ang is initially annoyed by how much
the newcomers have changed his Homeland.
Do you know what you did?
You'll just destroy them in fake grin for a stupid bath house. Well,
people around here are starting to stink.
Fleeing war. These refugees have found safe Haven,
but are accused by Ang of perverting.
It avatar could easily have ignored this aspect of warfare because in real life
we often do.
We may talk about the refugee crisis as it relates to a specific conflict like
the war in Syria, but we rarely engage with how ubiquitous a part of war.
It really is.
Almost every major conflict in recent history has created a huge number of
refugees.
The American civil war saw hundreds of thousands of southerners fleeing their
homes while the Russian revolution, India, Pakistan, partition, Vietnam,
and Korean Wars,
all forced to millions to relocate a recent study from Brown university suggest
that the war on terror launched in the wake of nine 11 has displaced some 37
million people to date. Basically anywhere you have a serious military conflict,
you have a serious refugee problem.
As the only remaining air nomad Ang himself is also a refugee realizing
that everyone he grew up with has been brutally murdered.
Ang is forced into the avatar state,
disappearing from himself and morphing into a swirling vortex of uncontrollable
pain and fury.
It's a powerful visual depiction of the depth of suffering caused by seeing your
home reduced to bones and ruins.
The damage goes far beyond the loss of the people he loved.
The monks were supposed to guide him in the ways of the avatar,
helping him to fully realize his own identity by connecting him to his past.
All of her identities are rooted to some degree in where we come from the
traditions and customs.
We are raised in lending us the sense that we are the continuation of something.
When these roots are ripped out, we can feel existentially.
But you were right. And the fire benders found this temple.
That means they found the other ones too. I really am the last terabit.
Ang experiences this and in especially literal way because he is the
reincarnation of previous avatars,
spiritually tied to his past cells to become the most powerful,
most fully realized version of himself.
This connection to the past must be nurtured and strengthened,
but without the monks there to teach him how Ang faces a much more arduous
journey, other suffer, a similar pain,
one episode depicts a town in which earth bending has been outlawed,
leaving young earth benders like Haru cut off from their cultural heritage in a
way which shatters their sense of who they are.
Problem is the only way I can feel close to my father now
is when I practice my bending, while.
It might seem like a heavy term to invoke here,
this is basically a portrayal of cultural genocide.
We're in the invading forces aimed to eradicate an entire culture by destroying
its artifacts and gaining its practices after China annex Tibet in 1950,
it demanded the Tibetan people assimilate to Chinese culture in the name of
unity.
Even the future Dalai Lama Tibetan Buddhism is Holy leader who is reincarnated
and discovered as a child must be approved by the Chinese government and the
United States and Canada native American culture was suppressed for generations,
my boarding schools and other policies,
forced native people to abandon their names, languages, rituals, and beliefs.
More recently,
ISOL has been known to destroy religious heritage sites and perform forced
conversions wherever they can.
And each case the goal is to erase the victim's entire cultural identity.
Even before his home was destroyed.
The war had a profound impact on Angus upbringing while the avatar is not
usually informed of their calling until they turned 16,
Ang was initiated four years early because of the looming specter of conflict,
the fire nation, not only steals Angus home history and adoptive family,
but a large part of his childhood as well.
War forces children to grow up far too fast,
speeding them through what should be the carefree portion of their lives to deal
with the harshest of realities and the early episodes.
We see Ang still desperately trying to deny this.
He knows he has a job to do and cares deeply about the world,
but he also really just wants to be a regular 12 year old kid and go frighten
some fish.
That's why we're here. Elephant, coy. I'm gonna ride it.
With his dad off, fighting in the war.
Teenage soccer even tries to take on the adult responsibilities of defending his
tribe from invaders and attempting to assemble an army of toddlers.
Fire nation could be on our shores any moment now, but I got it.
And no potty breaks.
While soccer's gang of a waist, high warriors is mostly played for laughs.
It sheds light on one of the darkest realities of warfare child soldiers.
In the second world war Jewish children across Europe took up arms as part of
the Jewish resistance fighting for the existence of their people. Of course,
on the other side of that war, Japan and Germany,
both had child soldiers fighting for them after showing how the water tribe kids
are drawn into defending their home avatar examines,
how the children of their invaders are pulled into it as well.
You're just a child. Well, you're just a teenager. And one episode Ang.
Is accidentally enrolled in a fire nation school.
He watches as his classmates are fed propaganda to convince them that the fire
nation is on the right side of history.
Question one, what year did fire load those in battle the air nation army,
the real world.
Parallels.
Aren't hard to find during the second world war elementary schools in Japan were
made to teach children according to the Imperial way,
framing Japan as a Holy land that students had a divine destiny to protect and
avatar.
Doesn't shy away from the psychological scars that come with being a child
soldier. Most obviously in its depiction of jet and his Merry band of Outlaws.
Having seen the fire nation wipe out their homes.
These kids have learned to meet violence with violence and formed a formidable
rebel squadron.
At first Jenna's crew seemed like swashbuckling freedom fighters.
Their new way of life provides them with a heroic sense of purpose and
adventure. Offering them a measure of retribution,
which nothing else will while we understand how they have become.
So radicalized,
the corrosive effect this has upon their humanity quickly becomes apparent.
You born guitar and then take him for a walk, a long walk.
They are willing to destroy an entire village full of innocence,
just to strike a blow against the fire nation,
cheering it as a victory for freedom.
The war has made them as ruthless as the enemy.
They despise the fire nation might play the role of avatars evil empire,
but this show takes pains to highlight the fact that things are mostly not so
binary.
Anyone that has been indoctrinated since birth or radicalized by revenge has to
be considered a victim of the war as well.
Even if they grew up to willingly participate in it,
we're creates generations of kids like Jett and Zuko with their grudges.
So deeply ingrained that they will never stop fighting.
But avatars exploration of this goes far beyond the simple revenges bed.
You have to forgive people message that you might expect of a family friendly
cartoon. It emphasizes how difficult forgiveness is to achieve in a world.
So scarred by war. Take the episode in which guitarra meets Hama.
An old woman who was developed by far the creepiest technique in the avatar
universe, blood bending,
while the cackling old lady with the freaky power seems like pure horror movie
stuff.
We find out that she originally created the technique while imprisoned by fire
nation soldiers. Along with the rest of her village,
blood bending allowed her to escape while everyone else perished.
It's hard to condemn someone for doing whatever it takes to survive in such
impossible circumstances. Things become more complicated again.
When we discover that Hamas has continued using her powers to take revenge upon
other fire nation citizens.
It's you you're the one who's making people disappear during the full moons.
Twist in the tale comes when Katara is forced to use blood bending,
to escape Hama putting her in the exact same position.
The old woman was in all those years ago,
crossing a moral boundary in order to survive.
The episode is a masterclass and playing with the audience's sympathies.
As it draws them into ever murkier, moral waters,
it asks the question of when the victim becomes a victimizer in their.
Own rights. That choice is not yours. The power exists.
And it's your duty to use the gifts you've been given to win this war at
Tara, a tried to wipe us out our entire culture. Your mother.
Ideas are followed up a few episodes later when Zuko offers to help Katara track
down the soldier that killed her mother,
having spent her entire life reliving her loss.
Katara imagines the soldier as a force of pure evil.
Once you finally meets the man himself,
she is shocked to discover how pathetic he really is a brow beaten, old coward,
living a squalid unhappy life alongside his bad tempered mother Katara.
Can't bring herself to kill someone.
So wretched and so has denied the emotional closure of taking revenge. Again,
the episode ends on an ambiguous note where choosing to rise above the urge for
vengeance can feel like letting evil, go on.
You did the right thing.
Forgiveness is the first step you have to take to begin healing,
but I didn't forgive him. I'll never forgive him.
One of the most appalling things about any given historical atrocity is usually
how many ordinary people facilitated it. Joshua Oppenheimer's documentary.
The act of killing made this unsettlingly clear by providing an up close look at
members of the Indonesian death squads who brutally murdered almost a million
people in the sixties, even as they reminisced openly about their awful crimes.
They never came across as anything other than regular, fairly unimpressive guys.
In some ways it would be more comforting.
If we could believe all evil deeds are done by her vertically evil people,
but it Qatar also finds out most of the foot soldiers are depressingly regularly
slipping back into regular lives. Once the shooting stops,
it's what philosopher Hannah rent would call the banality of evil.
Unlike these other characters,
what really marks Ang as our hero is that he remains resistant to violence all
throughout the show. Even after all the war has taken from him,
he is determined to find a way back towards peace.
I took away your fire bending.
You can't use it to hurt or threaten anyone else ever again.
When backed into a corner, he will fight to protect those.
He cares about such as when he transforms into the avatar state to defend the
Northern water tribe. However, afterwards,
we find him clearly traumatized by the events.
Everyone around him considers him a hero,
but Ang is horrified by the destructive power.
He unleashed tearing apart an entire fleets by himself while Ang is clearly
special in his commitment to nonviolence the show,
mostly avoids labeling good guys and bad guys,
rather it depicts a war ravaged world full of complex people,
struggling with trauma that is hard to overcome.
So what do you think is avatars eviction of war uniquely profound or does
Harry Potter do it better? Should we all be watching Gundam wing instead,
let us know in the comments big thanks to our patrons for your support.
Be sure to bend that subscribe button and as always, thanks for watching.
Later.
[inaudible].